Kelly tell us how we almost I mean you
were on this like Superstar trajectory
that yes you have gotten to now but it
almost came to a screeching halt after
one day with us tell us this is a true
story I almost got canceled before I
popped because we just tried just being
your [__] friend really [__]
riding with the homie just like whatever
I'm saying and the sad part is instead
of getting canceled I feel like we
should have got an award we kind of
single-handedly opened the country up I
think it's like literally in the middle
of time where people were spraying Lysol
with boxes we were having pool parties
yeah bragging about them on TV they're
trying to convince people it was the way
to go
looking back
we were in Florida and like no one in
Florida took us seriously so I was like
all right let's just write a country
song about life here
like even family from New York call me
they're like what's going on yeah like
what is happening like is everything
okay you're not taking this serious and
uh everybody we did some you know
watching right now we wrote this song I
think we were in Nashville I was doing
shows in Nashville yeah and you were in
town and we had been you know dming and
I was like yo can we pull up on you can
we just hang and I'm like what if we
write a [__] country song and you
organized like some legit country
brilliant singers and like composers oh
yeah and we sat down in your studio
which was in this like in the middle of
Music Row by the way in the house on
music right in the middle of right next
to Warner Brothers yeah that's right
where we were that day
yeah and we wrote we wrote open her up
yeah and by we I mean you guys wrote
and we worked with your punchlines yeah
some prominent people that we can't even
say yeah I've told the story last night
to Country some country radio guys
backstage and I can't say his name I
wish I could but a multi-platinum guy
was telling the same story because I was
talking about doing this today and the
radio dude was a big fan of the show and
I was like you know Bubba longstroke
that wrote that song is such and such
and he was like you're [__] me I was
like yeah dude we drug that dude out of
the house that day and by the end of the
song he was like I can't have my name on
it
and then I [__] up because I love
y'all so much I doubled down and put a
rap verse on it
I should have known something was up
when the other country dude in the room
was like yo I can't even have my name
and I was like let's shoot the videos
is like yo you're not taking covet
seriously enough that's crazy that's
crazy
that's a long stroke can we say who it
is Garth Brooks yeah yeah
get it man shout out to Garth bro
no it was it is a incredibly successful
country artist that uh shared his time
with us
in between Pig hunts he could have been
like full he showed up with blood on his
shoes
that he just was like threw on the
ground
yeah it was like a real experience and
then we wrote this and then you came
down to Miami to film it yeah that's
where I met you yeah yeah and party bro
and we I remember we were in the uh
we're at the house my house had a pool
in it
do you remember and then we had the two
girls that are now the heavy Queens
got you in a boat in the middle of the
pool and then you were like you were
like I think we ever got me in the boat
I remember it was a tough time
[Laughter]
yeah we had a couple of the Jaws lines
there you go
at one point you just go uh all right
all right I'm in the boat where the
[__] at the [__]
he said it even more cash he's like I'll
be here you put the two [__] right
here
kind of like what two girls were like
yeah we'll just sit right here
I said it in the most endearing way
though like yeah like you know I say it
I [__] grew up in the 90s and I talk
like it
okay and that wasn't what got me
canceled so what happened that song
comes out and then what happened I had a
publicist for no [__] like 72 hours I'm
not bullshitting I sent him the money
and they were high was um I've never
said the name Kenna I think
yeah which is like one of the biggest
people they represent Uh Kevin Spacey by
the way yeah
I've represented Kevin Spacey through
the whole thing I want to put that out
now for what you're about to say you
might need a publicist for that we send
them the money and they want you know
it's the first publicist I ever had by
the way so I'm all excited that it's a
crazy expensive and we sent on the money
and three days later they were like
they sent an email over to goes
we need to speak about this Andrew
Schultz song and I was like oh [__] and
the way it said at first I kind of read
it the other way like we need to speak
about this Andrew Schultz
I was like
this is it
funny so you calling up jollies
I was like you got morning TV or
something I was thinking this is it dude
and they were like we've turned around
and they literally sent me my money back
dropped me as a client that day they
sent me my money back
offended somebody
your money back please stand to say my
money wasn't green god dude they kept
Kevin Spacey as a client and I know that
because an agent called me he goes I
can't [__] believe this he goes uh
one of my friends is a girl who works
over there and she's rolling her eyes at
this [__] because they kept on Kevin
Spacey while people were saying that he
was murdering his rape accusers
so not only did he have accusers
kova doesn't even hurt kids you know
what I mean that's it kids are
completely safe
look I
I think it would have been one thing if
I would have like done it with Bubba
longstroke that'd be crazy but like I
did it with a comic I did it with a
comedian yeah and wrote it with a bunch
of Comedians and had a bunch of [__]
comedians in the video it was clearly in
satire yeah you know what I'm saying but
also 100 how we feel
comedy
it's the way I prefer my comment it's
like and we ended up being right because
the wildest thing we stood the test of
time through all this [__] you know what
I mean if my fat ass was down there not
worried about it I feel like that should
have been a Beacon of Hope for the whole
country yeah
you're putting your life on the line I'm
like yo [__] let's go you know what
I'm kovid's dream
yeah
I can't believe we made him come to
Miami
everything is open we loved it we went
bar hopping is when I realized how
divided the country is you were talking
about being in Nashville and they were
like you were like yo if you wear a mask
in Nashville people are gonna think you
have coped and be more scared of you
than someone who's not wearing a mask
that's true whereas in New York dude
people would get off elevators it was
crazy yeah well if you wore a mask in
Nashville during that time we just
assumed you were really sick you know
what I mean yeah and it wasn't even like
I was telling somebody about it it
wasn't a political thing for me it was
like just what I seen yeah when I real
when I went to Boston that year and they
were like I got in trouble for walking
down the sidewalk without a mask by a
police officer that's crazy I was like
whoa this is like a way different thing
up here than it was down there yeah you
know what I mean like it was it would
never get presented to us like it was
bad